zdf heute live einen schönen guten abend
und ganz herzlich willkommen ja kippt
oder scheitert die pflege impfpflicht
das ist die frage die uns heute
beschäftigt denn eins steht schon mal
fest die frage ob sie kommt und wann sie
denn kommt die wird wieder heiß
diskutiert eigentlich ist sie
beschlossen aber an der basis gemeint
sind die pflegerinnen und pfleger in
diesem fall teilweise auch die verbände
darum ort ist ganz schön und die
opposition allen voran die union macht
ganz schön druck führende köpfe in csu
und cdu sprechen sich inzwischen
zumindest für eine verschiebung aus wir
diskutieren das thema mit unseren gästen
als der wehren heike behrens sie ist
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der
spd-fraktion im bundestag und sie
vertritt die auffassung dass die
einrichtungs bezogene in pflicht
pünktlich bis mitte märz umgesetzt
werden muss allen schönen guten abend
und herzlich willkommen
anders sieht das udo recktenwald von der
cdu er ist landrat des landkreises st
wendel im saarland einen schönen guten
abend auch ihnen
direkt weil die cdu hat die einrichtungs
bezogen im pflicht doch mit beschlossen
im bundestag und auch im bundesrat warum
sie es jetzt da jeder sie fristgerecht
umgesetzt wird
die cdu hat in der tat aus überzeugung
zugestimmt allerdings auch in der art
dass der bund seine hausaufgaben macht
und sind jetzt wochen vergangen viele
fragen sind offen
arbeitsrechtliche fragen fragen der
lohnfortzahlung
fragen wie das betretungsverbot konkret
umgesetzt werden soll ganz praktische
umsetzungsfragen und die
gesundheitsämter werten aus meiner sicht
auch vollkommen den stich gelassen die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hat noch
vor ein paar wochen das
gesundheitsministerium des bundes
gebeten alle offenen vollzugs fragen
abzustimmen damit es ein einheitliches
vorgehen gibt sind viele wochen
vorbereitet ist in dem gesetz nicht ja
frau während also wir hören es
impfpflicht gut und schön aber wenn dann
in der praxis sowie ihr gesprächspartner
sagt gerade wenn da keiner weiß wie das
ganz umgesetzt werden soll dann hat doch
auch die bundesregierung ein problem
aber ich glaube eher dass tatsächlich
die menschen eine großes problem haben
wie eben nicht sicher sein können dass
sie in einer einrichtung leben in der
sie gut versorgt werden und zwar von
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
versorgt werden die alles dafür tun um
den infektionsschutz zu gewährleisten
das gesetz ist so verschlossen worden
wie sie es von ihm geschildert haben mit
breiter mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
wir sind einstimmig aufgefordert worden
von allen 16 bundesländern eine solche
einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht zu
beschießen und
die
bundesländer sind nun in der pflicht
diese dieses gesetz umzusetzen
und nachdem es aus der praxis problem
anzeigen gab hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium sofort den
kontakt mit den gesundheitsministern der
länder aufgenommen um gemeinsam darüber
nachzudenken was wollten benötigt es
noch an handlungsleitfaden an
ausführungsbestimmungen um hier die
länder zu unterstützen in der umsetzung
und ich habe erfahren dass gerade erst
die abstimmungen auch hier auf dieser
ebene abgeschlossen worden sind und das
selbstverständlich alles getan wird
damit dieses gesetz auch in der praxis
umgesetzt werden kann vielen dank schon
mal bis hierhin also wir sind da schon
mittendrin in der diskussion ich würde
gerne auch nochmal an euch den hinweis
loswerden gerne wieder mit zu
diskutieren auch eure fragen und
kommentare an uns zu richten 2 wer sich
vielleicht gerade schon mal vor pro
impfpflicht mit totes leid für die
geimpften pflegekräfte die die dummheit
oder asozialität ihrer kollegen wieder
ausbaden dürfen und seit jahren am stock
gehen für alte und kranke pflegen und
ihnen helfen will sollte verpflichtet
werden können das auch zu tun ich kann
ja auch nicht anwalt werden und sagen
ich habe nicht so bock auf gesetze das
einer meinung bei uns bei den usern und
eine andere gibt aber natürlich auch
oder beziehungsweise auch viele andere
ich bin pflegekraft schreibt richard
über youtube drei mal geimpft und sage
nein jede pflegekraft soll für sich
selbst entscheiden das ist auch eine
meinung die wir relativ häufig hören
hier in unserem netzwerk
so wir wollen bevor wir weiter sprechen
mit unseren beiden gästen noch einmal
den aktuellen stand überhaupt der
debatte euch zeigen lena sünder bruch
macht dass es geht es noch einmal um die
regelung zu der einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht wie es momentan der stand
der diskussion
am 10 dezember vergangenen jahres hat
der bundestag die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht beschlossen sie gilt unter
anderem für beschäftigte von kliniken
pflegeheimen und ambulanten
pflegediensten in einrichtungen für
menschen mit behinderung in arztpraxen
und bei rettungsdiensten spätestens bis
zum 15 märz müssen sie ihrem arbeitgeber
einen nachweis über eine impfung oder
genesung vorliegen oder darüber dass sie
aus medizinischen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können ziel dieser regelung
ältere und vor erkrankte menschen besser
vor einer ansteckung mit dem corona
virus zu schützen der arbeitgeber soll
den impf und genesenen status der
beschäftigten prüfen und die nachweise
auf verlangen auch dem gesundheitsamt
vorlegen passiert das nicht für das als
ordnungswidrigkeit behandelt und mit
bußgeldern geahndet
weil die gesundheitsämter sind gefragt
wie sehen sie denn da ihre behörde in
ihrem landkreis aufgestellt kriegen sie
das so hin
also die da selbst sind überhaupt nicht
in der lage das umzusetzen das werden
wir durch verwaltungsmitarbeiter
umsetzen müssen es ist ganz klar gesetz
ist gesetz wir erhalten uns natürlich
ein gesetz das bestand hat setzen wir es
um aber auch als
absolut unzureichend vorbereitet wir
haben jetzt versucht mal einen studien
zu entwickeln er um sie allein nach
diesem vorschlag werden wir elf
schreiben verschicken das aber zehn
wochen bis wir dann vielleicht ein
betretungsverbot aussprechen dass dann
beklagt wird sodass vor hat entschieden
wird ob man gedreht und zwar wurde
umgesetzt wird das zeigt auch schon dass
die gesundheitsämter in diesem ermessen
spieler und den sie auch noch ausüben
soll
es ist eine kann regelung und es sollen
attest vorgelegt werden ein ärztliches
ja aber kein fachärztliches oder auch
keine amtsärztliche es gibt 100 offene
fragen wie ich ihnen jetzt vorlesen kann
sagt ich habe selber lesen
sie haben schon ein paar fragen in den
raum gestellt und die sind ja auch in
der tat berechtigt also viele dinge wird
beanstandet seien eben nicht geklärt die
frage wer definiert wie ein
betretungsverbot erhält oder nicht nach
welchen kriterien gibt es
arbeitsrechtliche konsequenzen welche
konsequenzen gibt es da überhaupt also
untersagen einige unionspolitiker die
herren märz söder und tanz seien hier
mal genannt da habe der bund da habe
auch die ampel eben nicht geliefert frau
behrens was sagen sie dazu
denen sage ich dass die umsetzung dieses
gesetzes von den bundesländern geregelt
werden müssen und wenn die besagten
männer sich beschweren dann sollen sie
sich bitte bei den bundesländern
beschweren die hier ihre ihren auftrag
noch nicht in vollem umfang erfüllt
haben aber ich sage
gleichwohl bemüht sich sehr intensiv
darum im zusammenwirken zwischen dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium und den
gesundheitsminister der bundesländer
hier weitere handlungsleitfaden zur
verfügung zu stellen damit die umsetzung
gelingen kann ich möchte aber noch etwas
anderes sagen weil die umsetzung nämlich
vor allem in den einrichtungen und
diensten erfolg und alle einrichtungen
und dienste oder auch arztpraxen alle
anbieter im bereich des
gesundheitswesens wissen bereits seit
november dass diese einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht kommt und ich weiß
von ganz ganz vielen dieser
leistungserbringer dass sie sich jetzt
seit monaten intensiv darum bemühen
ihren mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zu überzeugen ihnen eben wirklich auch
leichte zugänge zum inseln zu
ermöglichen und für die die sich da so
bemüht haben und dabei auch erfolgreich
waren ihr personal zu gewinnen um eben
wirklich die bewohnerinnen und bewohner
der die patientinnen und patienten
besser zu schützen die müssen es als
ohrfeige empfinden wenn im grunde
diejenigen wie es jetzt vor ort
umzusetzen haben sagen ja jetzt kriegen
wir das doch nicht hin und das muss
alles ausgesetzt werden kann man es
nicht machen das ist rübergekommen
vielleicht gerade herr recktenwald dazu
sind die länder jetzt in der pflicht
also wie sehen sie das
dann ist das für mich anders weil es gab
nach ausgestaltung im sprechen darin
spielen bilden muss und das glaubt die
kinder an das
bundesgesundheitsministerium alle
ordnung volkswagen-cup zustimmen damit
es auch bundes einen geschmackvoll und
keinen auslegen des wettbewerbs gibt
ansonsten markiert des bundeslandes nach
eigenem gusto hier ist in ihre
hausaufgaben nicht gemacht ich muss
sagen ich bin ja auch und unterstützer
auch menschen davon zu überzeugen dass
ich ihn spielen lassen ich habe aber
auch verständnis für diejenigen die mir
aus voller überzeugung erklären warum
sie es nicht tun und ich will keinen
zwang ausüben schon gar nicht in einer
begrenzten gruppe von menschen und es
sind ja keine allgemeine impfpflicht an
es geht um eine bestimmte gruppe und was
gilt wenn nur durch umgehen und arbeitet
der betrieb aufrechterhalten werden kann
auch das ist eine barbie fans ungelöst
ist und ich kann das aus der praxis was
die kolleginnen sagt nicht bestehen aber
weil sie gar die allgemeine impfpflicht
ansprechen also da ist ja die offizielle
linie ihrer partei schon auch die dass
die beibehalten werden soll wie geht das
denn jetzt eigentlich miteinander einher
das ist also schon diese probleme gibt
bei der einrichtungs bezogen und die
gleichzeitig aber an der gemeinden
festhalten wollen eine impfpflicht hat
ja auf die pandemie berechtigung eine
ganz andere wirkung als wenn ich nur
bestimmte gruppe oder ein teil der
gesellschaft leben will und was sie
zwinge sich impfen zu lassen
deswegen ist es schon ein unterschied im
übrigen die allgemeine impfpflicht macht
muss man das nicht auch nur da gibt es
ansonsten überhaupt keine
konzern so dann wollen wir gerade unsere
runde noch einmal erweitern um unsere
kollegin sarah attacke sie ist die
leiterin der zdf redaktion recht und
justiz und wir haben dies um eine
einschätzung gebeten zur frage ob denn
die länder in diesem fall also ein
gesetz zur pflege impfpflicht einfach
nicht befolgen können oder dürfen oder
beziehungsweise die umsetzung einfach so
lange hinauszögern dürfen hier ihre
einschätzung dazu die bundesländer
dürfen die umsetzung der pflege im flick
nicht blockieren ganz klares nein und da
gibt es auch überhaupt kein vertun und
keinen spielraum die bundesländer haben
einstimmig im bundesrat für die pflege
impfpflicht gestimmt und müssen sie
jetzt auch umsetzen muss keinen soll
kein kann sondern muss das heißt hier
gibt es überhaupt gar keinen
ermessenspielraum
also kein ermessensspielraum vielleicht
dazu passen auch die frage von left is
either you tube wie kommt die cdu dazu
jetzt opposition spielchen spielen zu
müssen und politik für eine kleine
minderheit zu machen die unsere
gesellschaft in geiselhaft nehmen möchte
so jedenfalls ihre wahrnehmung frau
behrens wir haben es gerade gehört die
rechtslage ist eindeutig wächst was
können sie denn nun als bundesregierung
tun um die länder nun konkret zum
mitmachen zu bewegen zu zwingen
ich habe es ja eben schon dargelegt da
es in der praxis tatsächlich da oder
dort umsetzungsprobleme gibt hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium jahr
unmittelbar angeboten wie wir
unterstützen euch und hier ist eben im
zusammenwirken mit den ländern eine
entsprechende umsetzung slightly
erarbeitet worden und so wird es von der
bundesseite her unterstützt aber jetzt
sind wirklich alle beteiligten vor ort
aufgefordert weiter alles dafür zu tun
die beschäftigten in diesem besonders
schützenswerten bereichen von dem impfen
zu überzeugen und eben entsprechende
impf angebote zu machen
beratungsangebote zu machen und eben
tatsächlich die konkrete umsetzung auch
zu organisieren und da ist wirklich auch
jeder landrat gefordert dieses gesetz
geben in die praxis umzusetzen und eben
anwendungsorientiert auch entsprechend
zu arbeiten eine frage die man sich auch
oft stellt ist wie müssen die
pflegeeinrichtungen mit ungeimpften
mitarbeitern und mitarbeiterinnen
umgehen auch das haben wir noch einmal
unsere rechts expertin sarah tacke
gefragt
pflegeeinrichtungen müssen jeden
ungeimpften mitarbeiter melden und die
gesundheitsämter müssen diese meldung
aufnehmen und dann jeden einzelfall
genau prüfen und schauen gibt es hier
vielleicht eine begründete gravierende
ausnahme dass beispielsweise es
unmittelbar bevorsteht eine ungeimpfte
mitarbeiter dann vollständig geimpft ist
dann kann man sagen hier ist es
vertretbar und verhältnismäßig dass
dieser mitarbeiter weiterbeschäftigt
wird das sind aber gravierende ausnahmen
grundsätzlich gilt ein ungeimpften
pflegepersonal darf nicht mehr arbeiten
tätigkeitsverbot und die
gesundheitsämter sind angewiesen das
auch durchzusetzen
ja direkt einmal jetzt handel gehört was
die einrichtungen was die
gesundheitsämter juristisch machen
sollen machen müssten was machen sie
denn konkret wenn das gesundheitsamt
ihnen jetzt namen von ungeimpften
mitarbeiterinnen oder mitarbeiter nennen
was können sie dann tun
wir als landkreis das gesetz umzusetzen
das habe ich ja auch
philipp ein gutes gesetz umsetzen und
kein gesetz bei dem 200 offene fragen
gibt weil die gesundheitsämter einen
ermessenspielraum ausüben müssen und
dabei für eine situation gestellt werden
die im einzelfall unheimlich schwer zu
beurteilen ist und ich sagen wir sind ja
als landkreise auch dabei einen
umsatzschwund plan zu erarbeiten und
einen umsetzungsplan der nach meiner
kenntnis jetzt vorsieht dass wir elf mal
anschreiben mehrere bußgelder parteien
bis es letztendlich nach wochen zu einem
betretungsverbot kommt dass dann
möglicherweise beklagt wird und dann
noch einmal ausgesetzt werden muss
insofern ist jetzt sich das gerne um
aber ich würde lieber ein gutes gesetz
umsetzen und es ist ja auch die frage
wie gehe ich etwa mit nicht vollständig
geimpften um wie gehe ich mit denen um
die mit nova wachs eine impfung haben
alles fragen und da kann ich ihnen vor
während es nicht recht geben diese
leitlinie oder richtlinie die liegt
nicht vor wie es die nicht bekannt und
die gesundheitsämter werden hier im
stich gelassen frau behrens das ist ein
konkreter vorwurf wie können sie den
kasten
da ich habe es ja jetzt schon drei mal
gesagt dass für die umsetzung die länder
zuständig sind und trotzdem der bund die
länder unterstützt hier diese landung
sliten tatsächlich zur verfügung zu
stellen und ich bin sicher dass dieses
auch in der praxis ankommt aber ich
bitte sie doch einmal auch den blick
anders herum zu nehmen heranbringt so
müssen sich mal in die menschen
hineinversetzen die in einer zum
beispiel in einem pflegeheim leben wir
müssen darauf vertrauen können dass
diejenigen die sie pflegen diese
betreuen versorgen auch im
hauswirtschaftlichen bereich dass die
alles dafür tun um den infektionsschutz
rechnung zu tragen
dafür haben sie die verantwortung das
ist auch eine professionelle
verantwortung wie in diesen
einrichtungen wahrgenommen wird und die
wirklichkeit ist dass die allermeisten
einrichtungen gerade in ihrer region
aber auch bei uns hier in baden
württemberg haben diesen anspruch auch
längst erfüllt weil sie seit langem
wissen dass in den einrichtungen nimmt
dann die große gefahr eines infektions
ausspruchs da ist wenn eben ein
wesentlicher teil der beschäftigten
nicht geimpftes tag haben wir leicht
voller erfahrungen alle miteinander und
deshalb sollten wir jetzt alles dafür
tun die menschen wirklich vom impfen zu
überzeugen ja frau behrens der punkt ist
rübergekommen dankeschön ich lese gerade
nochmal 2 kommentare vor christiane
gerade bei youtube sie ist dringend für
eine einrichtung bezogen die impfpflicht
ja dringend ebenso in kitas und schulen
überall wo menschen sich nicht
ausreichend selbst schützen können und
engen kontakt haben eigentlich gilt
hierzulande eine sorgfaltspflicht
gegenüber schutzbefohlenen die leider
sei zwar ja nicht wirklich ernst
genommen wird allen voran von der
kultusministerkonferenz so ihre
einschätzung
und dann aber natürlich wie gesagt auch
weitere gegenstimmen bei youtube wir
brauchen jeden aus dem gesundheitssektor
egal ob geimpft oder nicht impfungen
müssen eine freiwillige entscheidung
bleiben ohne nötigungen und
zwänge ein nächster aspekt ja wie groß
ist das problem der impfpflicht im
gesundheitswesen insgesamt offenbar kann
man sagen nicht überall gleichermaßen
gravierend auch hier bei uns gehen die
ansichten darüber auseinander professor
rainer saalfeld er ist
geschäftsführender direktor der atem mit
kliniken insgesamt 17 häuser
deutschlandweit dort hat man bereits im
januar die impfpflicht für mitarbeiter
eingeführt kündigung gibt ganz wenige
seinen drei oder vier
klagen gibt es auch relativ weniger 4
ist der heutige stand sind also
ausnahmeerscheinung und eigentlich haben
wir einen innerlich guten dialog mit
unseren mitarbeitern gegensätzliche
positionen aber wir versuchen
unverändert sie zum impfen zu bewegen
man versucht natürlich sie zum impfen zu
bewegen herr recktenwald offenbar wir
haben es gerade gehört gibt es in diesen
klinikverbund immerhin 17 häuser nicht
so große probleme damit was machen die
denn anders als die einrichtungen bei
ihnen im landkreis
also ich weiß ja nicht ob das eine frage
der quantität ist wir haben im saarland
sehr hohen wurde am schluss sagen dass
wir als land reise gemeinsam mit dem
land und den einrichtungen sehr intensiv
dabei sind eben formularen zu bieten und
die menschen das auch wahrnehmen jahren
weit über 80 prozent
aber ich sag mal ich habe trotzdem
verständnis für den einen oder anderen
der das aus nachvollziehbaren gründen
vielleicht nicht tut und die frage der
pandemie bekämpfung habe das ja schon
gesagt eine allgemeine impfpflicht ist
was völlig anderes das betrifft jeden
muss natürlich kontrollierbar sein und
wir haben durchaus einrichtungen in
denen ungeimpfte arbeiten die sich
trotzdem schützen und ich sagt man mit
einem tagesaktuellen pcr-test bin ich
unter umständen besser geschützt als mit
einer impfung die drei monate her ist
und ich habe auch mit leuten gesprochen
die mir wirklich sehr nachvollziehbar
erklären konnten dass sie aus
persönlichen gründen auch aus bestimmten
erfahren und sich nicht impfen lassen
ich bin einfach dagegen dass man jeden
ein zwingen muss ja das ist ja auch eine
sozusagen ansicht die man vertreten kann
ja auch anderswo vertreten wird markus
der mäuse gockel hat schreibt man sie
über youtube bevor die cdu jetzt meckert
sollte man sie mal daran erinnern dass
der spanne von ihrer partei stammt und
aus meiner sicht nur ein positives in
seiner amtszeit hatte und zwar einen
corona test naja ok also das ist wie
gesagt die meinung von herrn mäuse
gaukler aber herr recktenwald eine frage
kann ich ihnen ja auch nicht ersparen
denn es ist ja nicht von der hand zu
weisen dass am 27 märz die
landtagswahlen sind im saarland und eine
wahl bei der natürlich auch die cdu
gerne wieder stärkste kraft werden würde
liegt da nicht die schlussfolgerung nahe
dass sie mit dem thema auch wahlkampf
machen wollen gerade
nein dann dürfen wir überhaupt keine
politik mehr machen und wenn es so ist
wie auf der gegenseite gesagt wird dass
die mehrheit für die impfpflicht ist
dann wäre das ja auch kein
wahlkampfthema
ich glaube die landesregierung ist sie
stehe ab konkreten umsetzungsprobleme
bewusst und da haben wir einen sehr
engen austausch ich bin der
landesregierung auch sehr dankbar dafür
dass es sich der probleme unserer
gesundheitsämter annimmt und wir
dringend hier einheitliche vorgaben und
vorgehensweisen brauchen weil es wird
schwer sein für die mitarbeiter die das
machen müssen nachher nach ermessen zu
entscheiden ob jemand jetzt ein
betretungsverbot erhält oder nicht
vielen dank herr recktenwald wir
verabschieden sie an dieser stelle frau
behrens bleibt noch kurz bei uns und
wird sich gleich mit den ansichten eines
pflegers bei uns auseinandersetzen danke
nochmal ins saarland vorher aber zeigt
uns jürgen kehl dass die korona lage
tatsächlich inzwischen doch eine andere
ist immerhin das als zu beginn der
pandemie
so kommen der vierten woche 20 22 mehr
als eine million fälle dazu der
altersdurchschnitt 30 jahre ein prozent
dieser infizierten müssen ins
krankenhaus 0,02 prozent der patienten
versterben ein vergleich in der letzten
woche 2020 gab es in deutschland die
bisher verheerendste cupid bilanz gut
120 tausend menschen waren infiziert
fast zehnmal weniger als heute aber alle
noch ungeimpft der altersdurchschnitt 49
jahre zwölf prozent mussten ins
krankenhaus der anteil der verstorbenen
4,62 prozent fast jede zwanzigste cupid
erkrankung endete tödlich also aktuell
gibt es mit omikron zwar viel mehr fälle
aber auch dank impfungen viel weniger
gravierende verläufe
wir erweitern unsere hunde noch einmal
und zwar um alexander jorde er ist
krankenpfleger und buchautor auch ihnen
einen schönen guten abend hatte und nach
wir haben gerade noch mal eben beitrag
gehört viel weniger gravierende verläufe
inzwischen braucht es da aus ihrer sicht
noch eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht
also ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen
bezüglich der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht ich sehe das nicht unbedingt
als notwendig an aber aus dem grund weil
ich denke dass wir zum gleichen
zeitpunkt eigentlich hätten einführen
müssen die allgemeine impfpflicht und
ich ehrlicherweise nicht nachvollziehen
kann warum dieses thema der allgemeinen
endlich moment so raus gezögert wird
weil das ist am ende das entscheidende
instrument um die pandemie zum ende zu
bringen und ich glaube wir sollten
langsam auch mal anfangen rücksicht auf
die vielen menschen zu nehmen die sich
im leben kamen die sich immer an
maßnahmen gehalten haben und die sich
immer noch einschieben müssen weil eben
eine minderheit sich nicht daran hält
und nicht mitmachen möchte und beim
thema einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
muss ich auch sagen dass ich zum
beispiel dieses framingham lege endlich
ganz fatal finde weil das einzige glaube
ich was im moment von dieser ganzen
debatte hängen bleibt ist ein sehr
negatives sehr negatives bild von
pflegeberuf oder von den menschen die
dort arbeiten die an der stelle sei das
auch mal angemerkt von anfang an die
ersten waren wo es noch keine impfung
gehabt wo masken mangelware waren pro
schutzausrüstung mangelware waren waren
wir diejenigen die in den zimmern
standen die angehustet worden von den
ersten corona patienten und das haben
wir alles über uns ergehen lassen und
jetzt wird so eine debatte geführt die
irgendwie den eindruck erweckt als seien
wir die pandemie treiber und das finde
ich schon sehr schade und da sollte man
eher richtung allgemeine impfpflicht
schauen um tatsächlich die pandemie dann
auch an der stelle zu beenden
nachvollziehbar wie sie argumentieren
und ich glaube es wird auch keiner die
verdienste der pflegekräfte hier
irgendwie in abrede stellen gleichwohl
es ist ja so dass doch auch gerade aus
den verbänden auch von der caritas war
das heute wieder zu lesen zum beispiel
einfach die befürchtung kommt das eben
mit der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht doch ein mangel an
pflegekräften entstehen wird also werden
auch konkrete zahlen genannt da gibt es
in den wirklich hohen bereich von
hunderten oder tausenden sogar und dann
stellt das stellt sich doch die frage
woran liegt das und vielleicht lassen
sie uns dann noch mal einblick geben
herr jorde warum lassen sich der
offenbar noch was pflegerinnen und
pfleger in relativ großer zahl dann eben
doch nicht in frage
da würde ich erst mal die frage in den
raum werfen was ihre datengrundlage für
die behauptung überhaupt ist weil ich
habe sich jetzt schon so oft gehört ja
die pfleger und pflegerinnen dresdens
die berufsgruppe die sich ein wenig
impfen lassen möchte aber irgendwie gibt
es keine validen breit angelegte umfrage
irgendwie die auch repräsentativ ist
unter pflegekräften wo es darum geht die
bereit sind die überhaupt sich impfen zu
lassen und das auch mal
gegenübergestellt zu anderen
berufsgruppen und was ich eben auch an
beispielsweise dem sendungstitel so
fehlerhaft findet zu sagen pflege im
pflicht es ist ja keine pflege im
pflicht es ist eine einrichtung bezogen
im pflicht die eben alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in der
patientenversorgung in diesen
einrichtungen umfasst unter zehn
beispielsweise auch erst im ärzteblatt
gehen andere berufsgruppen zu und es
wird irgendwie die berufsgruppe der
pflegenden draußen fix und so getan als
seien wir diejenigen die dort eben nicht
bereit werden sich impfen zu lassen und
ich möchte einfach wenn man so eine
debatte führt dann sollte das auch
fakten basiert sein und irgendwie fehlt
mir ein bisschen an den fakten weil das
einfach so in den raum geworfen wird das
sagen ein paar einrichtungsleitungen das
wird hier und da in bestimmten
gesprächen aufgenommen aber eine
wirklich breite datengrundlage die das
auch belegt dass sich viele pflegekräfte
eben nicht impfen lassen wollen die
wurde mir noch nicht vorgelegt ist denn
diese annahme aus ihrer sicht falsch
also übertrieben ja definitiv
also man muss natürlich auch aufgliedern
pflege ist ein sehr vielfältiger beruf
es gibt sehr sehr viele unterschiedliche
settings wo menschen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen bereichen arbeiten mit
unterschiedlichen qualifikationen und
ich kann natürlich nur für meinen
subjektiven eindruck sprechen aber wenn
man sich in einem krankenhaus um schaut
vor allem auf den vielen
intensivstationen wo eben auch die
korona patienten behandelt worden da
kann ich mich noch erinnern als die
ersten impfungen da waren haben wir uns
praktisch darum gerissen dass wir so
schnell wie möglich diese impfung über
aufgekommen weil wir ja jeden tag in
diesen zimmern standen wir haben
natürlich ffp masken auf gehabt aber
wissen sie wenn so ein patient vor ihnen
liegt der bach ist aber höchst infektiös
ist die anrufe sind und sie merken ich
habe hier am heizen ein bisschen was von
dem kleben der mich gerade angehustet
hat dann wollen sie so schnell wie
möglich geimpft werden weil sie sehen ja
auch jeden tag die menschen sterben die
kurve haben sie sehen wie schwer diese
erkrankungen verlaufen kann und ich kann
mir eben nicht vorstellen dass es da
sehr sehr viele gibt in diesem bereich
die eben keine impfung haben wollen dass
es vielleicht einzelne personen gibt
oder in bestimmten einrichtungen
gruppierungen gibt oder in bestimmten
regionen wo grundsätzlich in der
gesamten bevölkerung eine niedrige
impfquote ist beispielsweise in
bestimmten regionen im osten das dort
entsprechend auch in den pflegeheimen
vielleicht eine niedrigere impfquote ist
das mag durchaus so sein aber dass es im
allgemeinen so ist das ist in der pflege
eine große gruppe an personen gibt die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen das
glaube ich nicht und das ist nicht mein
eindruck und da gibt es auch keine daten
dient es bisher belegen verstehe weit
ich weiß frau behrens also ich meine mit
diesem thema schon des öfteren
konfrontiert worden zu sein auch in den
medien und auch eben tatsächlich durch
verbände die das gesagt haben und die
befürchtung dass eben da also ein großer
sport entstehen könnte an pflegekräften
die habe ich mir mit sicherheit nicht
ausgedacht habe ich da eine falsche
wahrnehmung wie wir nehmen sie das wahr
ich glaube dass das genau richtig ins
ließ der harrier gerade geschildert es
gibt einfach auch innerhalb der pflege
in den krankenhäusern in den ambulanten
diensten eine hohes
verantwortungsbewusstsein und deshalb
ist der anteil der menschen die dort
leben
sind von sich aus schon sehr viel höher
als in anderen gesellschaftlichen
bereichen und ich finde er hat auch
recht zu sagen jetzt muss der schritt
kommen hin zur allgemeinen impfpflicht
weil wir nur so und schützen können auch
für das was ein virus entwicklungen noch
auf uns zukommt wenn wir in einem
pandemie habs gehen in einen nächsten
herbst gehen wollen ohne
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen dann
brauchen wir es dass wesentlich mehr
menschen in unserer bevölkerung geimpft
sind bis dahin und deshalb brauchen wir
jetzt den schritt hin zur allgemein in
pflicht auch in
verantwortungsbewusstsein und
solidarität mit all jenen die eben
tatsächlich in diesen besonderen
sensiblen bereichen wie in
krankenhäusern oder pflegeeinrichtungen
arbeiten verstehe morgen für unser thema
auch übrigens eigentlich ganz
unwichtiger tag denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht meldet sich zu
wort es geht um die frage ist die
impfpflicht für pflegeeinrichtungen
verfassungskonform dazu nochmal die
einschätzung bzw überhaupt die
vorausschau von unserer kollegin sarah
attacke
morgen wird das bundesverfassungsgericht
entscheiden ob die impfpflicht für
pflegeeinrichtungen mit dem grundgesetz
vereinbar ist dass eine eil entscheidung
denn mitte dezember hatten um die 50
betroffene verfassungsbeschwerde
eingelegt und in dieser entscheidung
haben die richter nun richter das
verfassungsgericht eine folgenabwägung
vorgenommen das heißt sie schauen ganz
konkret welche folgen hat es für die
betroffenen wenn dieses gesetz ab dem 15
märz ihr leben verändert für ihre
körperliche unversehrtheit wegen der
impfung und auch das tätigkeitsverbot
ist natürlich ein gravierender eingriff
in ihre grundrechte das ist die eine
folge und die andere folge ist natürlich
der gewünschte schutz der schutz des
lebens und der gesundheits der besonders
schwachen diese folgen werden
gegeneinander abgewogen und wie die
entscheidung ausgeht dass erfahrene
morgen
also ein spannender tag frau behrens mit
welcher erwartung schauen sie dem
richterspruch morgen entgegen
ich hoffe natürlich sehr dass diese
einrichtungs bezogen nebenpflicht
bestätigt wird weil wir dann auch eine
gute grundlage haben um die allgemeine
impfpflicht auf den weg zu bringen
herr jorde haben sie auch bestimmte
erwartungen was die entscheidung in
karlsruhe angeht
es ist ehrlich gesagt egal wie sich da
entschieden wird weil ich glaube dass
das eine maßnahme ist die uns nicht viel
weiter bringen wird ich glaube wir
brauchen einfach die allgemeine
impfpflicht und ich bin dreifach geben
wird ich würde mich auch vier oder fünf
mal impfen lassen wenn es not tut aber
ich glaube dass wir endlich maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen die wirklich ein ende
der pandemie herbeiführen um eben auch
die vielen menschen zu schützen die sich
an die maßnahmen gehalten haben und eben
unter vielen anderen dingen leiden die
nichts mit corona zu tun haben wenn sie
gerade sagen es müssten noch weitere
maßnahmen ergriffen werden vielleicht
könnten sie da gerade noch mal ein paar
nennen herr jordan aus ihrer sicht was
müsste jetzt demnächst passieren neben
vielleicht der allgemeinen impfpflicht
ich denke nicht viel mehr als die
allgemeine impfpflicht weil es ja im
moment so ist wenn ich auf eine
veranstaltung bin oder irgendwo und da
sind nur geimpfte dann kann mir ja nicht
wirklich viel mehr passieren vor allem
nicht wenn man gewusst hat ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass haben wir eben
auch an den zahlen gesehen im
krankenhaus zu landen oder in schweren
verlauf zu haben wenn man gewusst hat
ist oder zumindest doppelt geimpft ist
ist sehr sehr sehr gering und wir können
das ganze oder dem ganzen einfach nur
entgegentreten wenn wir alle geimpft
sind und man muss auch langsam
möglichkeit mehr rücksicht nehmen auch
die menschen die auch einfach wieder
leben wollen die an der gesellschaft
teilnehmen wollen die soziale teilhabe
leben wollen und das ist eben nur dann
möglich wenn wir eine breite impfquote
haben weil diejenigen die gepustet sind
die haben nichts zu befürchten wir haben
noch diese ganzen maßnahmen nur noch um
die intensivstation zu schützen weil es
eben zu viele menschen noch gibt die
nicht geimpft sind und wenn die die
erkrankung bekommen wenn die sich
beispielsweise mit micon infizieren
besteht eben eine hohe gefahr dass sie
in der auf der intensivstation nannten
und nur aufgrund dieser personen die
eben nicht geimpft sind haben wir
überhaupt die ganzen maßnahmen auch wenn
wir alle geimpft werden dann wollten wir
das alles gar nicht mehr weil es dann
eben wirklich nur ein schnupfen eine
erkältung mehr und in ganz ganz seltenen
fällen mal entzünden im krankenhaus
aufenthalt führen würde aber wer geimpft
ist der musst nichts mehr befürchten und
das ist ja das worum es im prinzip geht
ja in der tat diesen zustand wünschen
sich wohl alle wieder herbei ich danke
ihnen beiden ganz herzlich dafür dass
sie sich die zeit genommen haben heute
vielen dank alexander jorde auch vielen
dank nochmal heike behrens und auch an
euch nochmal vielen dank fürs mitmachen
ich will vielleicht gerade noch mal 2
kommentare ein mal pro einmal contra
vorlesen schleenbecker über youtube in
medizinischen pflegerischen berufen
würde ich die verantwortung und fürsorge
für andere voraussetzen leute die hier
nicht geimpfte enthalte ich in diesen
berufen für fragwürdig weshalb haben sie
dann diesen beruf ergriffen und contra
alena löwen schreibt uns über youtube
ich bin geimpft mit jedem einzelnen in
meinem team der nicht geimpft ist und
vielleicht deswegen gehen muss bin ich
solidarisch und unterstütze jeden ich
bin gegen eine pflicht also es gibt da
nach wie vor zwei lager das war die
debatte von uns heute zu diesem thema
wie gesagt noch mal danke fürs mitmachen
euch einen schönen abend und bis
demnächst auf wiedersehen